nachdem ich vor einer Woche bereits auf
die bildschirmzeit meiner Zuschauer
reagiert habe schauen wir uns heute mal
gemeinsam die Hintergründe
von euch an ich habe ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt keine Erwartungen und mir ist
beim Fahrradfahren tatsächlich eine
Mücken ins Auge geflogen deswegen bitte
keine Kommentare zu meinem Auge aber los
geht's mit dem ersten Hintergrund
tun
[Musik]
das ist keine scheiße ich habe wirklich
keine Ahnung wo ich da schon wieder
reingefasst habe aber es ist vertraut es
ist keine Scheiße machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten Hintergrundbild und zwar
diesen mir
einem Pferd
gehen wir allerdings mit hohen
Erwartungen weiter über zu Bild Nummer
drei
hat irgendwer von euch irgendwie ein
cooles als Hintergrundbild ja meine
Damen und Mädchen im Hintergrund Nummer
vier ist nämlich laserlauf unten steht
einfach sogar Lauch Modus was nicht mehr
das ist sowas gibt
aber gut
mach mal weiter mit dem nächsten
Hintergrundbild und zwar Sandra
oh mein Gott das ist gar nicht Sandra
oder ist das Sandra ich weiß nicht ob
das sandra ist es sieht eins aus wie
Sandra aber so ein Bild würde ich kennen
von Sandra das hier ist auf jeden Fall
das sechste Hintergrundbild was ich
heute rausgesucht habe es ist einfach
ein Hund der beschissen hat
ey sorry es ist wirklich einfach nur
beschissene
beschissen deswegen
ist das nächste Hintergrundbild
es ist
einfach Klopapier ihr seid alle
am arsch
entweder sind eure Hintergrundbilder
komplett beschissen oder ihr habt nur
noch 15 standardgramms mit zugeschickt
wie hier einfach Manfred von Ice Age
aber gut wir schauen mal weiter und
gucken ob sich das Blatt eventuell
wenden könnte sowie wenn man bei einer
Klausur dann am Ende der Klo so erfahren
hat das ist noch eine Rückseite gehabt
in my phone now put it down ihr
oder das hier
sorry aber
du kriegst doch Albträume wenn du das
siehst das ist doch bodenlos
ist das nicht der Chipmunk aber gut
meine Damen und Herren ich würde sagen
alles was wir uns bisher angeschaut
haben ziehen wir aus unserem Kopf raus
schmeißen es weg und gehen mit komplett
frischem Atem und einem komplett leeren
Gehirn das haben wir schon Brasilien wir
schauen uns das nächste Hintergrundbild
und zwar ist es Patrick
ich muss dabei irgendwie no joke immer
an Sandra denken moin servus moin bei
welchem Hintergrundbild ich auch an
Sandra denken muss ist dieses hier
einfach Schreck im Bikini was soll das
denn wieso habt ihr denn alle keine
schönen Hintergrundbilder die einzige
Person die mir wirklich ein
wunderschönes Hintergrundbild
zugeschickt hat was einerseits kreativ
ist aber auch so eine sexy ist
ausstrahlt aber auch passt und schön
aussieht und sympathisch und freundlich
und nett
du kriegst der Woche was auch ein ganz
schönes Hintergrundbild war was mir
zugesendet wurde ist das hier einfach
das Dick und Doof Logo
kann man schon fast Monat keine Folge ne
wir sind Verhandlung keine Sorge wir
sind sogar auf der wirklich Zielgeraden
mittlerweile es geht zu 99% in den
nächsten Wochen weiter ein bisschen
Hintergrundbild
hat mir ein Kollege zugeschickt Leo ich
habe nämlich seinen Namen mal in den
Sand gepisst und er fand so süß dass er
das seit drei Jahren als Hintergrundbild
hat und das hier
habe ich mit reingenommen weil es klar
auf der einen Seite ein schönes Foto
aber auf der anderen Seite ey es tut mir
wirklich leid für alle Dortmund Fans es
ist Wahnsinn das ist diese Mannschaft
verkackt hat nicht Meister zu werden das
muss man wirklich einfach so klar und
deutlich sagen wenn du zu Hause am
letzten Spieltag nicht gegen meins
gewinnen kannst menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten Hintergrundbild und zwar
diesem hier das sind zwei Personen in
komischen Outfits mit komischen
Schwimmbrillen aber das krass ist an dem
Bild ist einerseits das hier natürlich
die doof hinter gehört auf Spotify aber
auch passiert
er hat um 14 Uhr den Termin luca ist ein
Lauch das ist zur Anzeige gebraucht
genauso wie dieses Hintergrundbild
also
jedes Mal wenn ich mein Handy entsperren
würde würde ich einfach ein Herzinfarkt
kriegen wenn ich sowas sehen würde oder
auch hier bei
ich meinte
warum sie hier ist einfach komplett im
Jahr 2010 hängen geblieben mit just do
it tomorrow das sind so richtige dead-
ich mache das ja nie
ja wissen wir das gelogen ist das ist
auch wieder so ein Herzinfarkt
Hintergrund
wenn du gerade im Handy bist und
irgendein Typ kommt angerannt und will
Dir das gerade aus der Hand klauen und
guck dich noch so an und klaut das an
und läuft dann weg so weil ich verstehe
euch nicht vielleicht soll ich mal zum
Ohrenarzt gehen
ja vielleicht auch
oder generell zu
irgendeinem Arzt mal oder so aber gut
meine Damen und wir nehmen mal wieder
alles raus meistens weg und gehen
komplett unvoreingenommen in die letzten
10 Hintergrundbilder die ich hier
rausgesucht habe die eben zugeschickt
habt auf Instagram Laser Luca gerne
folgen
ich glaube einmal im Jahr was hoch
Instagram
dieses Hintergrundbild hier fand ich for
real richtig geil es ist kein
Hintergrundbild im Sinne von ey der
Hintergrund ist voll krass und da
passiert richtig viel sondern das
eigentlich Hintergrundbild ist wirklich
nur ein schwarz roter radialer Verlauf
also ein kreisförmiger Verlauf von
Schwarz geht es ins hellrote rein aber
die Person hat die ganzen Apps angepasst
dass das so passend ist dass das Rot ist
dann alles passen zum Hintergrund und
die ganzen Logo Scanner die Widgets
geändert ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht
ich habe da gar keine Zeit für wenn ich
euch mal meine Homescreen zeige ich habe
kein einziges Widget da drauf
das ist wirklich ich habe die das
langweiligste Handy Layout der Welt aber
gut machen wir weiter mit ebenfalls
einem langweiligen Handy Layout und zwar
im Hintergrundbild mit Sandra
kommen wir nun zu einem nächsten
Hintergrundbild wo ich überhaupt nicht
irgendetwas abfälliges sagen möchte
ist eine Hund einfach ein Ratte oder
halten und dann Hamster der sich
festhält ich weiß nicht
also ich weiß ich weil ich hoffe einfach
dass ihr die Hintergrundbilder von euch
extra geändert hat für das Video
[Musik]
komm
ich kann nicht
ich hätte jetzt gekackt ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir die letzten
sechs Hintergrundbilder jetzt noch mal
eben fix und Schnelldurchlauf machen
denn wir haben eine Katze die einen
Mittelfinger zeigt ich weiß nicht ob das
irgendwie Photoshop ist
höchstwahrscheinlich weil Katzen mehr
keine Finger dann haben wir eine Ente
die im Hintergrund irgendwie eine Straße
hat und wahrscheinlich gerade auf dem
Motorrad ein selfie gemacht hat wir
haben noch eine Ente oder ein Schwan ich
weiß es nicht äh die irgendwie Hände
gefunden hat ein paar chains eine Brille
und eine Kippe im Maul dann haben wir
wieder zwei Affen die einfach in seiner
Schale sitzen und sich irgendwie
gegenseitig anknochen oder kuscheln ich
weiß es nicht was sie da machen dann
haben wir auf jeden Fall als vorletztes
Hintergrundbild noch nicht pissen sind
in der Walachei und als allerletztes
Hintergrundbild Batman